on Tuesday morning ESPN which has been
in a losing battle to keep its
subscribers issued a new set of
guidelines recognition between sports
and politics ESPN public editor Jim
Brady acknowledged the oddity of
releasing those guidelines after a
presidential election but he said quote
we are living in unique political times
which explains the revised guidelines
for discussion of political and social
issues according to ESPN vice president
Craig Benton he said the Trump selection
was the essential factor behind the new
guidelines the first part of the
guideline is a recommitment to objective
journalism quote our audiences should be
confident our original reporting of news
is not influenced by political pressures
or personal agendas unquote of course
that's not going to help much CNN
believes the same thing and they're
reporting reporting and slanted have
waited left the left version of
objectivity says that a story once
decided upon must not be overtly
political but this ignores selection
bias which decides which stories are
important to cover in the first place
ESPN's heavy focus on Caitlyn Jenner for
example pushes a political agenda
through selection bias as well as
political bias ESPN does make two more
important changes to the policy first
they say that hard news reporters and
editors at the company should not make
any public statements in any form that
would reveal their political biases
that's absurd it doesn't solve the
problem of political bias in reporting
itself but the most important change is
the encouragement of more political talk
from commentators quote outside of hard
news reporting commentary related to
political or social issues candidates or
office holders is appropriate on ESPN
platforms consistent with these
guidelines the presentation should be
thoughtful and respectful we should
offer balanced or recognized opposing
views as warranted we should avoid
personal attacks and inflammatory
rhetoric in other words talk politics so
long as it's left us Mike Ditka lost his
job for speaking in favor of Donald
Trump against Barack Obama on NFL
countdown Curt Schilling was ousted for
the great sin of comparing radical Islam
to Nazism Chris Broussard was slammed by
management for expressing his religious
view of homosexuality Brady himself has
stated in the past quote internally
there's a feeling among many staffers
both liberal and conservative that the
company's perceived move leftward has
had a cycling effect on discourse inside
the company and has affected its public
facing product consumers have sensed
that same leftward movement alienating
some ESPN's far left is Amit certainly
certainly alienated me I used to watch
ESPN religiously now I can't even bear
to walk
for more than 15 minutes and stretch
since it's impossible to escape the
leftist propaganda izing that's not
going to change under the new rules
let's see ESPN hire some conservatives
and let them talk rather than ousting
them the moment they disagree with the
prevailing leftist orthodoxy then we can
talk about it for your discourse until
then ESPN should shut up about politics
altogether or risk watching its ratings
continued to tank and subscribers
continue to cut the cord I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show we have an
exciting show lined up for you today in
just a few minutes we're going to be
having on fh buckley fh buckley's
professor over at george mason
university school of law and he has a
new column at which he says the Donald
Trump should pursue nationalized health
care so we'll be talking to him about
that plus we have to get to all of the
developments in Syria we have to get to
the fact that Steve benen is no longer
on the National Security Council he's
been ousted and his security clearance
has been revoked for the National
Security Council and we'll talk about
obviously be Susan Rice scandal but
first I want to say thank you to our
advertisers over at blinds com so you
have window coverings that are old there
in crappy shape and you need something
that's going to look nice and didn't
gonna cost you an arm and a leg that's
what blinds calm is for so instead of
you having to hire a specialist to come
into your house and measure everything
and then he'll come back with something
you don't like and you replace it it
takes forever instead you go to blinds
calm and you get a free online design
consultation you send them pictures of
your house and they send back custom
recommendations from a professional of
what will work with your color scheme
and your furniture and specific rooms
and then they'll send you free samples
to make sure that everything looks the
same as it does online and every order
gets free shipping and then if you miss
measure or you pick the wrong color then
blinds calm will remake your blinds for
free so if your screw-up doesn't matter
blinds calm we'll eat the cost and they
will make sure that you get the blinds
that you want they've been it really
easy for you there's no excuse to have
the the blinds that look like and for
their they're from some sort of ghetto
you know get a horrible apartment that's
destroyed so make sure that you go over
to blindside come and check it out and
for a limited time you get twenty
percent off everything at blinds calm
when you use the promo code been so
blind calm use that promo code button
that make sure they know that we sent
you and also make sure you get twenty
percent of everything which is a solid
deal since it's already a very a four
competitively priced blinds.com promo
clip been twenty percent off everything
from full would blind cellular shades to
roller shades blinds.com promo code been
and there are some rules and
restrictions that apply okay so the the
media continue to insist that there's
nothing going on with this Susan Rice
scandal so yesterday because I was a
stuck at the airport all day we couldn't
actually do the show yesterday but I do
want to talk about the Susan Rice
scandal and why it's important so here
is the reason that the Susan Rice
scandal it is important it's important
for three reasons so to Rita backup well
we found out over the weekend and a
little bit of monday was that basically
Susan Rice's the National Security
Advisor under President Obama had been
requesting what they call unmasked
intelligence reports unmasked raw
intelligence from the intelligence
community in other words there's a
paragraph that would come in and it
would say Russian ambassador sergey kiss
Lee act was talking to us person one and
said well blah blah blah blah blah and
so she would say okay who is us person
one I want to know the name of that
person well if there is no illegal
nefarious activity at play then it
really shouldn't matter who us person
one was but she was specifically asking
for any time there was a trump
administration official a trump campaign
official rather and then after his
election and from transition official
she was asking that all those people be
unmasked apparently she had a database
and Excel spreadsheet in which he was
keeping all the information about the
various members of the term transition
team and Trump campaign who had talked
to foreign actors even though there was
no accusation no evidence of wrongdoing
which is targeting it is targeting now
it's not wiretapping because again this
is all the stuff that the intelligence
community was picking up an incidental
collection so I want to be very careful
about how we discuss this so that we are
factual it is Susan Rice sort of spying
on the Trump administration in the sense
that she is using a trump filter to go
through all of the information that's
being gathered by the Intel community
that's not the same thing as like in the
lives of others where the government
says I want you to go spy on this person
yeah it's not what's going on here at no
point in Susan Rice say i want the
intelligence community to go and tap
Trump's phone for example she said if
Trump's name comes up in the
communications unmask him now the reason
that's a problem it's legal to do that
the reason it's a province an abuse of
power if you're just keeping tabs on
your political opponents you know their
next move or just keeping tabs on your
political opponent so that you can
presumably leak it out to the press
which is what happened with Mike Flynn
the national security adviser who
followed Susan Rice if that's your
purpose then that is nefarious it may
not be illegal the leaks are illegal the
unmask you may not be illegal but if you
unmask and then tons of people have
access to all this information and then
it leaks that's always partially your
fault so it is clear at this point that
the Obama administration did target the
Trump team they didn't target them with
specific wiretaps but they did target
them in reviewing the information they
were looking at it through the lens of
what are the from people saying and can
we use that in any way as the wall
street journal editorial board said mr.
rice would have no need no obvious need
to unmask Trump campaign officials other
than political curiosity also worth
noting right slide so rice was
specifically asked about whether she
whether she knew about any of the
intelligence gathered on Trump and she
said she didn't know anything about any
of the intelligence gathered on Trump
what she actually said was that she knew
nothing about surveillance of the Trump
team this also does make theories about
the relations between Trump and Russia a
lot more strained because if she was
seeing all of the raw Intel and they're
on till then telling or something really
nefarious wouldn't have come out already
wouldn't we know about that already
wouldn't you be out there on the sunday
shows saying listen we know a lot of bad
stuff about Trump team and there's it's
going to come out eventually which is
why we need an investigation but she's
got nothing and the and the Obama team
has nothing and so they've got a problem
on their hands because basically they're
monitoring Trump and they came up with
nothing so Susan Rice was on television
yesterday when she came out and she
denied that she unmasked the Trump team
did you seek the names of people
involved in to unmask the names of
people involved in the trunk transition
the Trump campaign people surrounding
the president the president-elect let me
begin order to spy on them and
absolutely both absolutely not for any
political purposes to spy expose
anything but let me take the name of
Mike Flynn I lead to nothing to nobody
and never have it never would but let me
explain this first of all Andrea to talk
about the content of a classified report
to talk about the individuals on the
foreign side who were the targets of the
the report itself or any Americans who
may have been collected upon
incidentally is to disclose classified
information I'm not going to do that the
allocation right there the idea that the
Susan Rice would never disclose
classified information this
administration was the leakiest
administration until now I mean was a
super leaky administration the Obama
administration that continuously leaked
American and Israeli national security
information they leaked national
security information an increasingly
high rate as the years went on nor to
push a political agenda the idea that
nobody in the Obama administration would
leak is silly also i like how Susan Rice
may be telling the truth here but I like
when she says I didn't look at any of
this for political purposes okay how do
you define a political purpose so maybe
she didn't leak it maybe she's telling
the truth but there is no way that it
wasn't for a political purpose I mean
obviously if you come up with no
evidence and you're just keeping tabs on
people who are coming up in the
incidental surveillance and you're just
asking for every update on Trump why
would you do that if it didn't have a
political purpose really unclear Rand
Paul is right he says that we need to
call seasoned rice and she needs to
testify under oath the facts will come
out with Susan Rice but I think she
ought to be under subpoena she should be
asked did you talk to the president
about it did President Obama know about
this and he is exactly right meanwhile
the media are downplaying this so here's
the question why are the media
employments you can see a selection bias
on TV right so watching bias exists on
every Network so CNN is now being sued
on diversity grounds I guess and they're
not covering it the Fox News is in
trouble with Bill O'Reilly because
they're all these new allegations about
sexual harassment by Bill O'Reilly
they're not covering that basically a
lot of the network's don't cover stuff
that they don't want to cover if it
doesn't help them so fox news of course
is all up on the Susan Rice stuff but
they have not been particularly up on
any of the call man afford stuff
meanwhile the folks on CNN are over the
moon about the pool man afford stuff
former Trump campaign manager they're
all over the moon about that but they
have nothing to say whatsoever when it
comes to the susan rice stuff now two
things can be true simultaneously it can
be true that there were a bunch of
people related to the Trump campaign who
are suspiciously close to Russia it can
also be true by the way that there's no
proof of collusion and it can also be
true that Susan Rice was inappropriately
using the power of government in order
to keep tabs on her political opponents
but look how the
median treat this they treat this they
immediately dismiss the scandal then
they wonder why people think there's
media bias Don Lemon here's some lemon
basically dismissing this out of hand
and Clint floor The Washington Post
today calls the latest claims about
Susan Rice anatomy of a fake scandal
ginned up by right-wing media and Trump
so let us be very clear about this there
is no evidence whatsoever that the Trump
team surveilled or spied on worthless
spied on illegally there is no evidence
that backs up the president's original
claim and on this program tonight we
will not insult your intelligence by
pretending otherwise nor we aid and abet
the people who are trying to misinform
you the American people by creating a
diversion not going to do it diversion
from what it's a new store diversion
from what from from Prussia I mean I
understand that CNN has to devote 27
hours out of every twenty-four to trump
in Russia at least when they're not
covering Malaysian airliner 360 or
whatever that that Malaysian airliner
was the Doublemint thought was eaten by
a black hole but it's this is ridiculous
Chris Cuomo on TNN the block of wood
masquerading as a human anchor here's
what he had to say want you to believe
he is the victim of a crooked scheme
those are his words and here are our
words there is no evidence of any
wrongdoing and in fact if anything the
NSA asking for identities was a
reflection of exactly how much traffic
there was involving Trump people and
foreign players the White House blasting
the press for not reporting on another
fake scandal being peddled by right-wing
media that is day 75 of the trump
presidency okay just insane okay so he
says that the reason that Susan Rice is
keeping tabs because there was so much
traffic so he turns it back against
Trump that it's nefarious but again no
proof that anything nefarious went on
again demonstrating that the media have
a particular agenda on all of this and
that agenda is to get Trump it is not to
tell the truth we want to stop here for
a second before we bring on fh Buckley
professor buckley from the from the the
george mason school of law of the Scalia
School of Law I want to I want to thank
our new endorsers over at proflowers
I've used ProFlowers for years whenever
I'm out of town I send my wife flowers
wherever I am and the way that I do that
is I go to proflowers.com they are
always fresh they're always great they
always lasts for seven days to
guaranteed fresh for seven days or your
money back they have a seven-step
quality check the flowers are always
beautiful if something breaks they
replace it we've actually had that issue
and proflowers has done that for me
right now proflowers is a special offer
just for our listeners you get ten
dollars off your purchase of 29 bucks or
more so $29 purchase becomes a $19
purchase thanks to proflowers it is a
great service if you want to make your
significant other happy on make your
wife happy you wanna make your mom happy
this is the way to do it there's nothing
that people appreciate more than flowers
from as I say I travel a lot when I'm
out of town I always make sure to send
my wife flowers so she knows that I'm
thinking about her and I've been using
for years long before no response sir i
was using proflowers calm because they
are the best in the business and you can
help out our show when you use pro
flowers and you go to proflowers.com and
you use the show the code is Ben show
Ben show so make sure that it's been
show not just Ben Ben show is the promo
code at proflowers.com at checkout to
get that special deal or you get ten
dollars off any any sale of twenty nine
dollars or more if you got a birthday or
an anniversary or you're late you're a
month and a half way for Valentine's Day
because you're a crappy boyfriend
whatever it is proflowers.com is the
place to get it as I've said there's a
reason that I've used them for years
they have 100 blooms bouquet and a dozen
red roses they also totally unique
specialized plant gifts it's just a
great service and you should definitely
use it again use the promo code Ben show
Ben show at checkout to let them know
that we sent you and also so that you
are and also so that you get that
terrific discount okay so as we have
professor Buckley online okay terrific
joining us now on the bench Shapiro show
is Professor fh buckley he teaches at
the Scalia law school at George Mason
University his most recent book is the
way back restoring the promise of
America and we're having professor
Buckley on because he has a new column
in which he suggests that president
Trump should actually pursue
single-payer health care professor
Buckley thank so much for joining the
ventured hero show well thanks for every
minute so let's jump right in so you
wrote in this column that president
Trump should basically ignore repealing
Obamacare he should instead focus on the
imposition of single-payer health care
and you try to justify that on
conservative grounds which is
to single-payer isn't really
conservative you write the Trump said
that he wanted a plan that would leave
no one uninsured the simplest way to do
this is universal health care on the
Canadian model with the right of
individuals who purchase a Cadillac plan
on top of this out of pocket I actually
agree that that's what Trump was
promising when he said that he wanted to
make sure that no one was uninsured but
he also promised hundreds of times on
the campaign trail to repeal Obamacare
do you think that those two were in
conflict was he fibbing to his base or
what I don't know if they're in conflict
or not but whether it does a matter of
verbiage but let's just talk about
whether or not something like the
Canadian single-payer plan makes sense
and I think it does and I think it does
because it I think would appeal to most
American voters as well all those
countries ahead of us on metra speaking
on the freedom have something like
single-payer so if one's worried about
economic liberty in America is one
should be it's not about single-payer
it's about a whole bunch of other things
to tend to get ignored ok so I agree
dude there are a lot of other things
that tend to get ignored but to say that
single-payer health care is not an
imposition on American freedom is just
not true it creates massive
bureaucracies it creates rationing as it
does in Canada it i think that the best
framework for thinking about this is
that as dan mclaughlin and national
review said you can have affordability
universality and quality you can have
two out of those three you can't have
all three and universal health care and
less in ordine Utley expensive it's not
going to be particularly great quality
but you know instead of arguing over the
merits of universal health care I want
to ask you because you you are a
constructors agree with everything you
stood by the way but go ahead that's
fine if you want to re if you want to
argue with that go for it well one way
of measuring quality is to ask whether
or not people are satisfied with what
they get Americans are quite
dissatisfied with what they get the
country whose citizens are most
satisfied with what they get is about
Canada I want to talk a little bit about
what Professor Buckley wrote here he
basically made the case then he was a
conservative professor Buckley portrays
himself as a conservative so I want to
ask him the question but he wrote in
August 2016 the Trump was actually more
conservative than a lot of the
conservatives who didn't support him and
I don't want to you know hit him while
he's off the air here but but the fact
is that measures the satisfaction are
not a particularly good measure of
whether a system is good or not
Americans are highly satisfied with met
cade and there are no improved health
outcomes from Medicaid but Professor
Buckley I don't want to hit you while
you're off the air there but I would
just argue that the measure of
satisfaction is not in my view a good
one because Americans are virtually
everyone is satisfied with welfare
systems it's very rare that people are
dissatisfied with stuff that they think
they're getting for free yeah well
another question to ask is is there any
movement in any of these countries to
get rid of what they you turn to some of
the most conservative politicians around
the people in Stephen Harper's cabinet
for example in Canada they would want to
touch it at all what they would want to
do is tweak it with respective things
like times you can make that better
there a lot of things you can do to make
it better it's a very different kind of
plainfield not otherwise when these
things were introduced but in general I
think what I'm arguing against is a
certain libertarian view that
entitlements are the problem and
entitlements you know what that is as
ordinary Americans as regular Americans
its services provided by the government
and in fact I mean Americans would not
be satisfied with anything less than all
people are covered I think that you know
the cast kind of libertarian streak as
something that is that is out of line
here but again you know I think that's
it more traditionally American puter
tional and conservative you so do you
think it's conservative let me ask you
this do you care about the term
conservative at all when it comes to the
president truong because you wrote in
August 2016 that president Trump was
more conservative than conservatives who
didn't support him and you talked about
entitlements in that column for the New
York Post and you said that America has
quote a deeper kind of rot of departures
from the rule of law of corruption of
regulatory state on steroids of a
constitutional structure that lacks a
reverse gear and that has given us
wasteful laws the team impossible to
repeal I totally agree with all of that
but if you're talking about wasteful
laws that seemed impossible to repeal
adding new entitlement to the definition
of that and if you're talking about a
regulatory state on steroids then a
massive new entitlement that regulates
how people obtain their health care is
the definition of a regulatory state on
steroids well in fact you've got all of
that with respect to the present system
you have that great back to muck
Medicaid Medicare and so on you also
have a really perverse incentive with
prospective employers who are obliged to
carry insurance that makes them
non-competitive with respect to
companies in SE kehna
which don't have that kind of burden so
not only is it good for Americans to
have something like this but it's also a
jobs creation planets really win win so
do you think they saw and the question
why don't you fly up on what else
wouldn't have to do to shrimp is good
one that's well I mean to that
considering the debt is the vast
majority of the budget is these massive
entitlement programs it's very difficult
to it's very difficult to say that
should be cut unfortunately I think we
lost professor Buckley they're not much
we could do bad connection but my big
question to Professor Buckley is
basically I understand that people want
Trump remain in power but if they think
the Democrats are going to work with
Trump and they think that socialized
healthcare is conservative then why not
just become a Democrat I mean if the
point is just we're going to create a
new economic nationalism that involves
adopting every socialist position then
why not just do it outright and that is
the big question I think that remains
okay so in other news well get a bunch
of other news that I want to discuss
here but for that you're going to have
to go over to daily wire calm we're
going to be talking about this amazing
kendall jenner pepsi ad we're going to
be talking about what's going on in
Sierra we talking about band and ouster
so Bannon has just been basically Elstad
from the National Security Council I'll
explain why that happened and what that
means in life it's a good thing we'll
talk about all of that they get to go to
daily wire calm to do that daily wire
com eight dollars a month will ensure
that you can get a subscription that
daily why do I come in to see the rest
of the show live it means you can be
part of the mailbag in a couple of days
right now if you subscribe annually we
had a free signed copy of our very own
michael moses best-selling book thing
reasons to vote democrat a comprehensive
guide the it is a massive bestseller and
it is a great gag gift that you can give
your friends so go and check that out
over at daily wire.com or listen later
to itunes or soundcloud for the rest of
the show we are the largest conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
you